[Music]
[Applause]
he's John Smoltz he's a Hall of Famer
and he works MLB on Fox the World Series
analyst as well the new rules are out
John and I want to know John Smoltz the
pitcher in his prime with the new rules
how would you take advantage of the
pitch clock or the batter clock
well that would have been right up my
alley because uh you know the biggest
thing I loved about starting pitching I
get to go when I want to go and I was a
fast worker that was really really
something that was always taught to our
staff glavin Maddox myself whoever's in
the staff you know that was Leo's
biggest preach is let's go get the ball
and we were trained for that and so
you know information and everything
that's kind of slowed the game down it's
now trained to process more information
so I absolutely love this rule I love
every rule that's come into play for the
obvious reasons that people are going to
complain and they're gonna you know
baseball has been slow to change for uh
of the major sports and that's okay but
it's time and the players will learn it
they'll be fine it's actually going to
be worse for the hitters than it is for
the pitchers I know it's called a
pitcher's clock but it might as well be
called a hitter's clock
but so far runs are up batting averages
up
but you're saying it's going to be
tougher for hitters
I think it's going to be tougher for
hitters to True process the information
faster pitchers are going to have their
game plan already established and
they're just going to kind of you know
their full tail and nobody's really
massaging the strike zone they're trying
to pound the strike zone so hitters are
trying to get all that information
that's why they step out they're trying
to see what they have absorbed during
the day in my opinion there have been
some Notorious slow pitchers but that is
a minority and I think that the game in
and of itself with all these rules I'm
excited about every one of them I'm
telling you there's going to be
unintended consequences that are going
to affect the game in a positive way
everybody will get over it and I know
the narrative look I get it like people
are talking about oh I can't believe
you're making it you know easier for the
game to be played no that's not it the
data showing the game takes too long and
when the game takes too long and
philosophies are set in place you can't
go to an individual club and say I need
you to change your philosophy they're
not going to do that so rule change will
cause the philosophy change because
you're you would be stupid not to if
there's no shift and you're teaching a
guy to hit the ball hard then you'd be
you'd be not along the lines of uh your
analytics to take advantage of that who
was Notorious
kind of playing mind games with you when
they were in the batter's box
oh there would be some guys that you
know again the leadoff hitters were
different right lead off hitter's job
was to make us miserable because if they
could work the count work a walk then
they would work the bases they would
steal they'd make the hitter behind them
so much better because we had to pay
attention to him so leadoff hitters
would would play games they would step
out fake bunt work the count my battles
will go all the way back to Brett Butler
and we're friends and I told him he'd
never be able to bun on me and he was
one of the best bunners in the game and
that's how he he worked the the that's
how the game was played back then so
those systems and those are not fair to
compare to today because that's not the
same and you know stepping out of the
box then or taking way too long there
were ways to even those systems out
um they don't know those don't exist of
course no you don't throw it hitters
anymore Aaron judge was interviewed
during the game yesterday and he said
that you have to get back in and you
know it's quicker so I have less time to
think about the last pitch like he liked
it that all right let that go now get in
and get ready for that next pitch can
you understand that logic
absolutely and that's where the strategy
is going to come in if you've heard me
broadcast a lot you've talked have you
heard me talk about where the last pitch
was and how pitchers don't take
advantage of where the last pitch was
and what the hitter did in his reaction
in other words if I threw a high
fastball and he swung at it okay if you
take too long and you that hitter
forgets where that pitch is and you
bounce one in the in the dirt you're not
taking advantage of where that last
pitch is so what he's talking about can
work in an advantage for a hitter and
maybe a disadvantage for a pitcher so
that's going to be balanced out I always
pitched where the last pitch was and I
pitched off of it and I didn't want too
much time to go back because I didn't
want the hitter to reset I wanted him to
think about what he swung at and then
make him try to chase it a little bit
farther off I didn't want time to go by
so he could reset his brain I didn't
know that they had these pitching
machines we were out at the Super Bowl
we went to the Giants camp and they can
simulate the Clayton Kershaw's curveball
yeah in that wild that that they could
say like we're facing degrom or you know
that you can kind of plug that into
these machines
yeah those were starting to be birthed
when I was at the end of my career and I
was always you know
you know me I was always uh jabbing my
teammates going man I'd love to face me
but then then again no I don't want to
face me
and and they were like shut up smokes
and I said listen you know that's that
technology exists now and yes you can
see and shape pitches and get used to
shaping pitches the one thing that's
still difficult is the hand that you
know it's coming out of that hole in the
screen so you can you can start looking
at those pictures but the timing and
that's what I've always said about
pitching why do why do guys not use the
wind up more why are we like you're
letting the hitter see too much of a
kind of a conformed mini stretch
delivery so those things can be mimicked
and timed and I I I'm all for uh
whatever is is gonna help everybody but
I still think the pitcher has the
advantage when he uses the wind up would
you have rather faced glavin or Mannix
oh man either one I said listen
I said to glavin I said you better hope
you never go somewhere else because I'm
not done like the rest of those hitters
I'm gonna sit on your change up and so
we faced each other and it was right
after the All-Star break and I kid you
not I had pulled my hamstring and they
said to me like you need to take a start
off I said no it's lined up with glavin
I am not taking a start off I'm facing
him it's basis loaded one out and it's
in and I'm sitting on a change up and
I'm this is what I learned even if I sat
on the change up I couldn't hit it and
so I pulled it to shortstop it was like
a tractor pull running to first I had a
pulled hamstring I was trying to beat it
out and I couldn't I obviously faced
them both uh at the latter part of their
career but their their majest they were
so good at knowing what you were looking
for and giving it to you but not in that
area and hitters just weren't they
didn't go the other way and when you
don't go the other way against them you
lose I would love if I was a hitter to
face either one from the standpoint of I
knew it was going to be around the
strike zone yes it's it's the guy that
you're not quite sure like Randy Johnson
no way
not not interested not interested in
that at all where did you ever go up
there with fear
in your oh yes
yeah I tell you what I mean Pedro
Martinez struck fear in me just because
he was so nasty you were going to
embarrass yourself and I did right I did
get lucky and get one hit off of them up
the middle but you know what's weird is
Randy and I are in the same era
obviously we went in the Hall of Fame
together and we never faced each other
and so if it were possible and I and I
mean this like without getting severely
fine if there if there was a way to go
up there without a bat against one of
those guys you feared that you didn't
know if they'd throw a strike but you
also didn't know if you'd get it in the
ribs I'd go up there without a bat it
would mess with their mind
yeah
are you allowed to go to the plate with
no bad I I don't think so but you know I
honestly I tried to tell everybody when
Rick ankiel was going through what he
was going through and he we faced him in
the playoffs against the Cardinals and I
begged every hitter don't swing you know
go up there with the bat but don't swing
and no one could do it and then
eventually he worked his way into
trouble but there are certain guys that
if they saw you without a bat it would
flip it would freak him out and I don't
think they could throw a strike always
great to talk to you John thank you
buddy my pleasure you got it that's John
Smoltz he's a Hall of Famer and of
course works for Fox Major League
Baseball and fox